two weeks ago we introduced you to a
woman who found seven thousand dollars
of her own money sitting in the state's
unclaimed property fund well after our
story aired the treasury Department sent
out even more cash Heather Mills has the
update
several folks here in our Newsroom also
they discovered They too had unclaimed
money among the thousands who received
that unexpected payday so as of today we
have more than one billion dollars worth
of money for nevadans that was in August
now that figure slightly lower after our
eight news now story aired last month
there were more than a hundred thousand
searches online in just a week in fact
5900 people had a nice surprise waiting
for them Stacy Miller Eisenberg told us
what it was like when she found her
money honestly I was in shock the state
of Nevada's unclaimed property division
holds on to money that somehow got lost
along the way whether a misspelling
wrong address or a forgotten safety
deposit box in just one week the state
distributed more than five and a half
million bucks but there's still more
where that came from which everybody you
know search your neighbors it's a great
thing to say Hey you know by the bye
thanks for picking up my newspaper I
found a couple of thousand dollars for
you simply go to claimitnevada.org
see if you have any of that money
waiting Heather Mills eight news now